weddings starting soon how are things
going I was just ordained at WWE
internet ministry numeral for chicom but
I'm having some trouble with my speech
I'll get so far as a poem sounds
romantic
marriage is a contract between two
adults of different families
that's a cool and a fact they works on
two levels it feels a little impersonal
what did the officiants say when you got
married not much when gay marriage was
legalized we weren't sure if or when it
was gonna be struck down so speed was of
the essence do you Kevin yes and to you
yes yes we do we're married before we go
inside I'd like to say something you are
a wonderful person your friendship means
a lot to me and you look very beautiful
it's not okay weirdo let's go oh my
Oh
[Music]
oh sure mm-hmm
Gerry coach Dean Young Road is wrong
there's a twenty minutes a hitch quotes
before I even say Leslie's name what do
I do you know what time just speak from
the heart
okay you'll do great we are gathered
here tonight to join Leslie Knope and
Benjamin Wyatt in marriage it's been a
long and winding road for these two
lovebirds and they're so impatient to
begin their lives together they move
their wedding date up three months so I
say let's keep it short and sweet guys
just do it already I assume and hope you
prepared your own vows
Ben you want to say some stuff about
Leslie in my time working for the state
government my job sent me to 46 cities
in 11 years I lived in villages with
eight people rural farming communities
college towns I was sent to every corner
of Indiana and then I came here and I
realized that this whole time I was just
wandering around everywhere just looking
for you Leslie do you want to say some
stuff about Ben no okay well the first
draft of my vows which I wrote the day
after we got engaged clocked in at
around 70 pages oh but I don't have them
with me well maybe there's a copy of
them that's fine I think we can just
keep going okay
here's what I'll say that the things
that you have done for me to help me
support me surprise me to make me happy
go above and beyond what any person
deserves you're all I need I love you
and I like you I love you now
and now with the power vested in me by
the state of Indiana I now pronounce you
husband and wife
you may now here it is I really hope you
like it but if you don't I will kill
myself
Charles it looks amazing it's beautiful
how can I ever repay you get pregnant
use your body to give the world more
Jade Oh Lee crap all right I'm gonna
take Charles away from you now I will
see you up there
wait everything we're here where'd you
guys been you've sent us how to find a
band right I definitely remember doing
that it took a while but I think we
really nailed it
check this guy out we found him on the
subway hey I know you
you're molinos no we have never met I'm
pretty sure we have you sending me horse
blood no you like to buy a horse blood
no you know maybe we don't need music
for this that's totally fine we can just
skip that part of it keep daughter
holy crap Malik knows plays like an
angel Amy where it go hey Malik knows I
don't know you okay
[Music]
please be seated friends colleagues
gawking New Yorkers we are here today to
celebrate the marriage of Jake Peralta
and Amy Santiago I've known you both for
the last five years and it has been a
true pleasure to watch your distracting
childish rivalry evolved into a
distracting childish courtship and now
into what I'm sure will be a distracting
childish marriage I'm proud of you and I
love you both
permission to say it back permission
granted I love you sir Bobby captain now
I believe you prepared your own vows
yes I was going to do an Addams Family
theme drap but my beatboxer isn't here
that's the only reason it's not
happening so Ames today has been a crazy
day but I shouldn't be surprised because
we've had a lot of crazy days there was
our first date our first kiss the first
time you told me you loved me and the
day you told me you would marry me also
yesterday and the day before that and
the day before that because every single
day that I get to be with someone as
amazing as you is crazy to me I love you
and I'm worried about dancing in front
of our friends at the end okay well I've
been planning this wedding for the last
six months and if you told me yesterday
everything that was gonna go wrong I
would have had a panic attack that sent
me into the ER but I'm here and I've
never been happier
life is unpredictable not everything's
in our control but as long as you're
with the right people you can handle
anything and you Jake Peralta are the
right person for me but I do have some
bad news there is a bomb at this wedding
as well what your butt your butt is the
bomb
there will be no survivors I love you so
much you're my dream girl I love you too
I can't wait to spend the rest of my
life with you
ring bearer please bring the rings but I
thought cheddar was sick no oh my god
you got the robot there's a robot at my
wedding yeah I felt bad about how
everything went down today so I offered
to help that's nice
also you kept doing the thing where
someone gets to object to this union or
is that later not doing that you've
outsmarted me congratulations
okay moving on do you Amy Santiago take
Jake Peralta to be your husband
and do you Jake Peralta take Amy
Santiago to be your wife I absolutely do
[Music]
by the power vested in me by the state
of New York I'd like to announce that
your honeymoon vacation request status
has officially been moved from pending
to approved you're married you may kiss
the bride
[Applause]
[Music]
he comes
when streams are ripe and swelled with
rain
ladies and gentlemen we are gathered
here today to Mary and Maxwell Dwyer and
April Roberta
legend I guess I kind of hate most
things but I never really seemed to hate
you so I want to spend the rest of my
life with you is that cool yes is it my
turn
April you are the most awesome person I
have ever known in my entire life I vow
to protect you from danger I don't care
if I have to fight an Ultimate Fighter
or a bear or him your mom I would take
him down I'm getting mad right now even
thinking about it I'm telling you I want
to spend the rest of my life every
minute with you and I'm the luckiest man
in the galaxy
and now the ranks
[Music]
by the power vested in me by the state
of Indiana I now pronounce you husband
and wife
[Applause]
you